hello ladies and gentlemen and
welcome to today's webinar
titled multiple myeloma on the front
lines suspecting it was gay investing and
caring for it
my name is frank courage i am
director of scientific affairs for
bike inside for canada and i  will
be acting as moderator for this
event we are very pleased to
bring you this interactive educational seminar
which is presented by the
bush is sponsored by
balde insight lease insight is an
international company
headquartered in birmingham uk  uni where
it was founded more than 25 years ago by
university researchers
it is on these solid scientific bases
that de bike inside develops and
manufactures specialized products for
the diagnosis and clinical monitoring of
patients with diseases such as
as blood cancers or immune diseases
but for more information I
invite you to visit the website www point
de bike  inside points like before we
start i have a few
important points to mention this webinar
is meant to be interactive so i encourage you
to ask questions
throughout the presentation
you can submit your questions
by typing them in the box
note that a bereavement  which you can
access by clicking on the green
q&a button in the dot in the lower
left corner of the presentation screen we will
try to answer as many
questions as possible in the
time available
you can also expand the
presentation window by  clicking on
the icon in the bottom right corner and
if you have any
technical problem to see or hear this
presentation,
do not hesitate to click on the
support button at the top right of the window
or by using the green button
again killed n'a bottom left
as i said earlier this webinar
and educational so it offers
continuing education credits so
in pres  training will be completed you are
invited to click on the button it's
them who in the lower left corner
to access the page which will give you
instructions to follow in order to obtain
your training credits
so now I would like to
welcome your  presenter in fact
your presenter should I say for
this seminar it is doctor julie Côté
who is a young and talented
hematologist oncologist who obtained her
doctorate in medicine in 2009 at
the university of laval in quebec and who
completed her residencies in
internal medicine in hematology and medical oncology in
subsequent years,
she then specialized through
post-doctoral clinical training in
traditional air plasma cells at the
prestigious and internationally renowned canadian cancer center
that you
probably know the princess
margaret carter center in  toronto
she is now part of the
medical team at the university hospital center
of quebec where she is
am more specifically interested in
multiple myeloma and other diseases of this
family she is also a member of
myeloma canada and of the
2011 canada research network i now leave the
floor to doctor julie side for her
presentation
thank you very much to art it makes me  great
pleasure today to present to you this
webinar on multiple myeloma on the
front line it is a subject of great
importance because it is necessary to
recognize multiple myeloma
when they present themselves to us in the
clinic and it was important to
take care of it quickly so
for today's presentation I have
no conflict of interest and the
objectives will really be first to
recognize the symptoms and clinical signs
of multiple myeloma
then we will talk about the investigation
to investigate the presence of a
monoclonal protein part in an
adequate and complete way of course always remaining
in a first
line context because in fact it is a
webinar which is really for
family physicians and for interns
and what they are going to see patients with
multiple suspected convoy
in the front line
of our healthcare system is the latest
point in success to recognize
the importance  rapid support
visitation with multiple myeloma
and you will understand
why the presentation plan is
quite simple so we will target three
objectives firstly I will introduce you to
multiple myeloma
then we really see when
suspects and myeloma speak and for  that I
think is important to go through the
clinical presentation of myeloma but
also the different
diagnostic criteria and there are new
blind criteria those that were established
in 2014 and we will think through to
clearly clarify
what is meant by  a
multiple active violin secondly we will
talk about some investigations
requested to take stock and then
when referred and c  how to take
care of patients quickly on the
front line afterwards this will be the
conclusion is of course the question period
so we are production first of all
multiple myeloma the angel means
presentation is around 65 years old we
must keep in mind  head on the other hand then
having an echo exceptionally which
will appear in young adults
so it is not because a patient at 35
years old camille has been quoted to me as
completely excluded it is sure that it is
much less  frequent than in the
elderly for example from 75 to 81
but if it is suspected it should
not be excluded from the outset games based
on the age of the patient quickly canada per
day are diagnosed with
multiple myeloma have it is a disease  which is
still frequent today it is
unfortunately incurable but
more and more we have better treatments what
they excite a disease which makes
table and the median survival now
is better we are talking about about 7 to 10
years  of survival  e
median multiple myeloma years and a tumor
that originates mostar place cells from
the bone marrow
here you have
an illustration of the plasma site so
that's what we're going to see when we do a
bone marrow smear the plasma cells is
a bluish cell  with a nucleus and
a site in places so you can see the
lighter area around it which is quite
large
so this is what we will detect in the
bone marrow and then the plasma cells
are the cell which will basically secrete
our immunoglobulins  with antibodies the
problem becomes when this cell
of abnormal life and produces too much
minho globulin too much parra proteins
and in a monoclonal way I will come back to this
a little later in the destinations
but everything starts from the bone
marrow and this protein part  who
will be secretary brought the different
clinical presentations and
complications related to multiple myeloma
so when suspects and
multiple myeloma I start first with
to illustrate to you the multiple faces of
multiple myeloma
I have four examples of patients who
may present themselves to you
100 difference in different
contexts
just to express to you this multitude
of multiple cilic vigna faces
so the first patient a 68
year old man who  would present for example at
the emergency for a big decrease in
the general state with a
very important back pain on the assessment quickly at
the imi tunnel detection with a hemoglobin at
75 a renal insufficiency with a
crisis which threatens in 90 and in
high calcium have  do an X-ray of the
column quickly and we see that
multiple lithic bone lesions
so do you see that it is an example of a
very florid very acute craon
classic presentation generally well
recognized by first line doctors
because very obvious at the level of the
presentation
and it is of course a passer-by who
needs to be taken care of quickly, on the
other hand sometimes milon than those  presented
in a slightly more sly more
subtle way the second patient that I
present to you to be a 72 year old woman
who presents to be evaluated at the
office of one of the five families for
anemia progress 6
so there it is through the  assessment that we
will perhaps discover a
protein part to explain this
progressive anemia third patient could
be a 78 year old man who presents himself
once again to the office this
time perhaps from the internet or from the
nephrologist for  an evaluation of the nose
renal and progressive silence is
another example patient number 4 a
42 year old woman presented evaluated in the
office initially for pain in
the left shoulder
these chronic pains but which is
exacerbated recently for the purposes of basic
blood work which is normal  at that time
an X-ray of the left shoulder which
is also normal
so as is standard and would be
that it is more musculoskeletal pain
on the reference is you
therapy six months later she is
evaluated or without an appointment she is a
little better at the level of the left shoulder
but fatigue sets in and we do
a blood test and the hemoglobin
is lowered to 108 grams per liter we
is all in an appointment quickly the
lady already had
gynecological bleeding abounds unknown
history of iron-deficient halimi she is
prescribed iron and three months later
the pain in the left shoulder is
really incapacitating she consults
a mallet resonance again which is  asked
to clarify this and we find
multiple lesions including one of 2 cm in
the humeral head so you see
this fourth youngest patient
a very nostalgic presentation of
pain at the threshold in the left shoulder
initially a delay  approximately loos
then in almost three months so a
total of nine months of investigation until the
moment when the proof the patient
presents with a real complication either
a lesion struggle cyclo to  the
humeral head and in addition to the riddle
the sent you suspect multiple myeloma
and it's not always easy so
often on noah is going to show up with
symptoms and sometimes draw they
're completely non-specific and one
that can arise  say and present themselves at
different stages of the disease the
patient to present themselves floridly
as our first patient and the
need for treatment towards these
can also present themselves at the earlier
stage of the range has suffered monoclonal
significance and determined or is better
and we must therefore think about it and be on
the lookout because you see that myeloma
is a spectrum at the level of the disease
and this table there I liked it because I
find it very interesting it is a study
then which have  looked at the patients at the
time of their initial presentation
with the symptoms uniting them in
multiple london and as you see the
majority of these patients the water
presented to the doctors put on the front
line so that's e  st why
today's webinar it's really for and
train frontline doctors
on myeloma how suspected and
how figs and because
welcome this early way kit is
paramount because any delay in
diagnosis and  care of a
patient with nia long but you want to see
but complications and
again a supporting study this is a
retrospective study here of 92 patients who
were published in 2007 etc of patients who
were diagnosed  of multiple myeloma
from the years 2001 to 2006 and we
see that the duration of symptoms of more
than six months before the diagnosis of
multiple myeloma
was in more than 40% of patients,
so about half of patients have had
symptoms since  last six
months at least and they are in our
health system
unfortunately not suspecting
myeloma it causes the delay in the
diagnoses it remains very
sneaky symptoms and sometimes in this country it is
that at diagnosis look here at
the most common symptoms the
initial presentation
we talk about bone pain in
67% of cases and fatigue in 14% of
cases and why it is important to
diagnose it early here you have
the interval between the moment  of the
clinical symptom which arises and the
diagnosis and we see that when this
interval this delay in
the treatment lengthens, therefore free of no more
than six months, the rate of patients with
complications increases
significantly and when we are talking about
complications we are talking about
severe complications important
look in the rib behind
right column
when the delay of more than six months
that we fly atcd continuation of the limits
of bone complications and
kidney complications it's not bad huh
because you have a little  presenting with
a fractured medulla a
vertebral fracture that will generate pain
sometimes even the compressions to
relocate fo kidney disease  is patients
going to require daddy to go through the
ranks of a very advanced stage
so it's really stable of
complications that one should avoid at all
costs and i came some
interesting statistics here because it's
hard to know time suspected the
multiple myeloma for
sometimes so specific complaints of
pain on the ground in May of anemia of
fatigue in russia this is a data that
music according to a study in the united states
of all patients on the front line
with back pain  less than one
percent will have ichimaru a metastasis
so for sure it remains the less he
frequents frequent musculoskeletal pathologies
but he has to go
to these islands I will try to
give you tips or at
least information to be able to suspect  and
the hooks which we must push
further and see if the nicknames
denmark which will have kept patients
with osteoporosis and a patient on wines
presented fun monoclon paraprotein  al
or myeloma is for assessment
is elsewhere and if you have the
recommendations the
2012 guidelines for the diagnosis and
treatment of osteoporosis in canada and
we see that it is all the same recommended
for people who  present
with osteoporosis for example
sexual electrophoresis serum proteins
for patients with
vertebral fractures so at least it
is part of the assessment of osteoporosis
but if one of the faces of multiple myeloma
but as I am going to present it to you there
are multiple
faces indeed therefore the clinical presentation
of multiple myeloma
73% of the common very frequently it is
worth of the line then impatient
which presents itself with the emi is important to
think to be if there is an
underlying monoclonal protein part of
honeydew which  could explain this
year michel not without bone pain
almost half even 60% of patients
and especially a bone plate that will
be in the skeleton  e axial therefore the ribs
the column the pelvis of course excludes
apple in addition which could have a
morning higher level of the limbs but
it is mainly at the level of the
axial skeleton and be careful
because sometimes there can also be
symptoms of  compression their logic
due to an attack on the ground
then it can present with a
raised creativity in 50% of the cases not
that we are going to do a blood test where we
find an acute renal essence or a
deterioration of my chronic renal silences
but c  maybe it's a
protein part that could cause the damage
symptoms or if there may be
ccig lippert that she has even if can
be found but more than one -
let's wait around  of 30% tons
so still paul symptoms that
come to the fore by more the
limit of bone pain in the
foreground and weight loss in about a
quarter of the patients
I'm going to me if the spect because the
clinical presentation v  a
lot depends on the stage at which the patient those
above so we all go sir
symptomatic active who requires
advanced treatment of earlier stages
and the first is the stage and
really muses the range
monoclonal appetite of significance and determined
for years and evolve  their
indolent multiples then a very long
symptomatic multiple so the patients who
come to you can be
in one or the other of these three stages which is
why it is important to know
the criteria that define each said
ap
then if we speak  symptomatic multiple myeloma
because it's going to be without
the teacher the orim that you're going to discover
inclined and who
needs rapid treatment partial put in the shade
active who must be treated so here I
'm taking over these are the new ones  criteria
reign those that were developed in 2014
and it takes several criteria to
speak of a symptomatic multiple myeloma
is active the first
criterion here the c  either to have
plasma cells in the marrow that are
more than 10% abnormal
it comes out it's going to be it's going to be determined
with the bone marrow biopsy
so often it's going to be a
second line exam with the tarnish or
really a  examination that is worth it is
when you refer patients to the
reference women and it helps us to
determine the place the casnos
medullary cause and therefore the clinical stage of the
patient
so they place the same thing the air
of more than 10% or  again if we have a
lumpy or extra medullary plasma cell
which will be confirmed by biopsy and it
may be that you are going to see a
clinic not that who complains of a
new mass have done for example in the
cranial vault have done an imaging  and
hop we find a what is called a
place most man which is as you
see in the lower figure on the left 1-1
mode plasmocytes in connection with the water
around the iliac bone of the refuge and the bone
and  who hand that aspect of
plasmo  cytes years but when we biopsy
this mass launched plasma cells
that we will find or we can
find a hamlet of plasma cells at the
level of the skin and you see the photo
here it gives a house which can be a
little bluish viola c  is what
proves to us that it's plasma cells it's
a biopsy so often that all the same
the biopsy can be requested at the
first line or else the referral center will be and
do their part
to go and prove that we
really have  monoclonal plasma cells
either in the marrow or in a
classification this time so that's our
first criterion is the second criterion
it really takes the presence of a
criterion that will define it in the shade
so either it's the organ penalty  target or
what is new in 2014 prices is the
presence of a biomarker like crazy
through the head of a target organ it is the
famous crabs that we know and
I have just given you the different
variables of the  cable for this
put them back  in the lead
then when we say crabs the cic for
hyper that it 6 me of which you have
certain values ​​but when the
calcium is high sense and an antenna
of organisms which scores for a
diagnostic criterion of multiple myeloma
6 the rc for renal sufficiency  so
not that which would have a very
high creation or even a creatinine clearance
abc the to for the limit so
lahlimi it can be
canned hemoglobin without sauce and anemia which is
considered severe but it can also
simply be a drop in
hemoglobin quote relative to its
base level of about 20 grams per
titer so it can sometimes be
difficult to diagnose at
the borderline level always get a
basic idea of ​​the hemoglobin level station and
see if a drop the  6 which often
has undersized anomalous variable size
and b death for
bone lesions and it takes at least
one bone lesion worth is described
as a high school so you  s see if
the sap image is really holes then
cpoi the possible blastic but
lithic and you see on the
x-rays that we still
see the bone damage well but it could
also is identified now by tako
steps kahn because this  are examinations
much more sensitive to detect the
bone disease than a simple
X-ray and the lesion must all the
same have a certain
size approximately 5 mm believed there to be
considered significant therefore without
recapitulating when one speaks of  'a myeloma
this active which must be referred
quickly
hematology to start a treatment
it is a patient who will present
when you look at the line of the bo who
will present a crab element in the
first line therefore a hypercalcemia of
the renal insufficiency of the  anim or
lithic bone lesion in addition to
presenting the first criterion if you
look on the top line which is the
presence of normal plasmocy
plasmocytes  your monoclonals either that we are going to
go proven by the bbc no longer following me
or by the biopsy of the bone
marrow where we will highlight the
normal plasma cell population
since 2014 which is new is that we
also consider the presence  of certain
biomarkers as being equivalent to the
famous g that we know and as being
one of the criteria which have drawn a
triple a is worthy son of
active multiple myeloma and these biomarkers have
been established because it is not that
which goes  present and have a risk
of progression to multiple myeloma
which is assessed at more than 80% over two
years in its success of passers-by which is
worth a flight which will evolve and
rather than observe them and
unfortunately reach a complication such as
a  vertebral fracture
we will rather treat these patients
there early
then it is a bit like the famous patients
of multiple myeloma and dolan who were
observed previously but who were at
high risk of progress  tion that we
said no we consider it
active multiple myeloma and we will start
treating you early to avoid
this progression with muddy complications
and the biomarkers this is the
first has three the first is
to have  bone marrow plasma cells so
in me when we go to do the
bone marrow biopsy of more than 60 for that
so impatient who would not have any
crabs which would have a part in
circulating proteins and we make biotin -
go hop we find 72% of plasma cells
it will be a patient that we will
consider for treatment
the second bio thus marks the
light scenes the insee but who was trying what
is now available
and when we look at the light chain
involved on the unexplained therefore the
ratio of the chains  slight the ip series
when it is raised to more than 100 and
the chain I replied and at more than
100 milligrams per liter
it is a criterion when you see it is not
that which evolves over two years the  green has  u
risk of active multiple myeloma so
they are now also considered
as a criterion for the treatment of
multiple myeloma is sometimes a bit
controversial if we only think about this
criterion there I speak to them a little
later on the tesla waste niger
lips eric you  go see it's what
we use more and more because of its
sensitivity so it's part of our
basic assessment on the one hand protein
but it's also a value that can
fluctuate so it's a new
notion that is part of our 3 trillion
mark harley of asymptomatic myeloma
and the last session there is to
find phocas bone lesions on
MR again of
more than 5 mm or more at the
size of the MR lesion
I'm just telling you about
it for a few moments, it's an
imagery technique that is very very sensitive and
has been recognized as tracks in
faults to the south and sites also very
early so that's why  a that it was
gone now in our arsenal
of imaging in patients with ni in
london multiples to try to
detect the disease very
early
so I'm going to get cydia to
really summarize our new criteria since
2014 for the diagnosis of  an
active symptomatic multiple myeloma I would like
for the first line really
happened with a crab whose father
she put on is surprising
mimi or lesions their public is that
it is a passerby who must be and  ferry
quickly because from the outset we have a
treatment criterion sometimes it's not
always easy to know if it's
really linked with the parra proteins
it's our role we are in the
tertiary line at the center and
reference level of  do the bone
marrow biopsy sometimes push sig to
sion with resonances for example
to try to stage the
patient and take care of him
correctly in the clinic or if
you are going to the front line  is exposed a
lot at the earliest stage which is
called m bus the monoclonal apathy range
of six cases are and
determined roughly is that one a protein which is
there but which is your target level so
often the monoclonal protein ciric  va
is less than 30 grams per liter and
at the level of me we will have less than
10% of clown plasma cells therefore have a
little bit of protein they cause
no damage so you will not have
criteria that define the
famous myeloma  abou our famous 3 biomarkers and
there will also be no ease
of emilie dose the town hall of auch it's
a whole other chapter in itself maybe
just a point he sometimes know that
amyloids with spurs in  usually makes
friends the back shows up with a
weak clown mystery place who can
give the change for 1m bus but that's
where you have to be on the alert
sometimes there if you have suspicions
clinical friends  the eye in reverse
telco but that would be the subject of another  he
complete presentation
for indolent multiple
myeloma is that between two donations you
have a little more protein, so
a k series monoclonal protein + 30
grams per liter or a protein
and binary which is the most 500
migrants per 24 hours  or when we go to do
the rubble biopsy between 10 and 60% of
must places in the medulla
and once again these are people
who have no criteria that
best define my friend no fear
of biomarkers and there are no  dani
leyde aux either it is important
to distinguish between these two
stages and often I would like again
it is the reference center that
will distinguish between a bus and
indolent multiple myeloma because it takes
a biopsy the marrow  bone it will
perhaps take further bone imaging
such as a resonance the
column toe scan for example to clearly
define if the patient is at the level of
the mdus stage but they have bet full
dolan or  if on the contrary it is pure
stage of active myeloma
we discussed previously because
see the m bus the risk of progression
towards a million multiples is much
more reliable
we speak of points 5 1% per year
versus indolent multiple myeloma where the
risk of  progression towards multiple myeloma
and 10% per year the
first the first 5 3% per year
the five years of seniority 1% per year
thereafter so really the risk
is not the same so the clinical follow-up
but not the  even either he uses can
be very stable can be followed for example
where to go whereas with indolent multiple myeloma
knowing the risk of
progression greater towards a non-
active place see more is followed for
example or three to six months in mode
depending on the table  clinic the water
so in the front line when you have
a table ladies bus you have to know a
little about the risk factors for
progression of this single because even
in the entity of rumors whether it is
levels  risk waters so the risk factors
for progression when the parra
protein monoclonal series that is more
than 13 g per liter or the concern
is not if I have so a nigeria for
example or that the chain ratio
slight lips eric is abnormal either
less than 0.26 or greater than one
point 61 500 these are risk factors
for progression jane bus towards a
more advanced stage and see here
when one has 0 of these criteria the
absolute risk of progression  out of 20 88 better
it is very low we are talking about 5%
on the other hand if we put a patient who
would have the three criteria so for
example a ligea at 17 grams per liter
with an abnormal ratio of light chains
his absolute risk of progression out of 20
and towards multiple myeloma is 58%
so we are not talking about the same m cus he
starts to see when referred an airbus
I would like these two referred
when there is an education to carry out
a bone marrow biopsy
so if you present  it passed a
table  m bus water and he has an
unexplained line
unexplained significant or
progressive renal failure or even had nor by what
sign then we assume this protein has
a link with a
clinical presentation which could side for our
famous criteria of the cab
c  is a situation where a
biopsy of the bone marrow is carried out
if the patient presents
bone lesions also, for example, to
a suspicious imagery, we do not really know
where the lithic components really are,
but we will go and do a
biopsy month to  clarify the place
moscow's marrow
if we have a suspicion of amilly dose
as I mentioned to you earlier and we
have a weak clown we must go to
a bone marrow biopsy to
better support our assessment or even if in
the presence of  one of the risk factors
for progression so if I come back here
if we have one of the risk factors either
klaproth the protein apparatus and in high
than one gram per liter where it is  the
niger for example or that their ratio of the
chains the gerling series which is
abnormal if recommended to proceed to a
ticket if the bone marrow and the
why the why is better to
kill what the patient has actually m
drunk or is what the  patient is
rather put in the shade and doel 1 which should
be followed by this are closer
I end on the clinical presentation
of the honey have just slipping you a
word from the classification to the stands because
it is a presentation as well as you
could see a front
line clipping is a plasma this tome in fact
it is a cluster of plasma cells that will
present either at the bone level at
the soft tissue level
remember I showed you the images or when we were
talking about the diagnostic criteria
great with multiple symptoms
it is sometimes this stand placement will
present itself in a completely isolated way
that is to say that we will prove it by
biopsy it proves to us a plasmid falls
it will be referred on  patient will be
referred to the reference center for the
complete assessment in the marrow we will find
no plasma cells there then we will not find
any other bone lesion and none of the
criteria which drew myeloma will
be present these are patients that we will
approach their  by radiotherapy at
much higher doses
and therefore on the back if you want curative at the
level of the placement this volume is sometimes
it is at these envelopes can have
no damage at the level of the bone
marrow but sometimes one can have a
slight damage at the level of  the bone
marrow of this will be place moss falls with
minimal marrow invasion so
you see that multiple myeloma of
multiple faces can present itself at
different stages in different ways
often what we will see is the
incidental discovery during a check-up
blood hop we do a blood test and
we discover a part with a monoclonal profile
or we want to discover the myeloma
during a balance sheet which will be carried out for  r
the investigation of a clinical complaint
a recipient pain animates it they
attack fatigue
it is difficult she suspects and I
agree but you have to think about it you have to
stay alert is a new
association ask now when
we passed in front of us we suspect that
the cause of this symptom could be a
monoclonal paraprotein what
should we do as a
blood test is
to first do the basic test so a
formula  blood complete what I have from
the limit and if I have mimi it is to
take stock of the night because a
halimi could be for lack of iron
to be not complaints could
be from different positions origin
so  you still have to do a
blood test of the limit the
sedimentation rate will also help us
in cases of symptomatic active multiple myeloma
it's going to be very high
happy hillion creators whose
kidney test did I not know years rena
what accompanies, for example, anemia or
a high sedimentation rate
calcium calcium to always be
dosed at the same time as it
undermines because it is necessary to correct calcium
for albinism is what allows us
to be sure and secure that  'she
began to who accompanies the
clinical presentation quote the
microscopic summary of the urine also can be
carried out myeloma can present
with kidney damage kidney damage
sometimes everything from amyloid to
donations can sometimes give proteinuria
and a small  a little
a little hint that I give you here
during the blood test because
the cgso protein electrophoresis can
take sometimes uncertain to obtain in the
clinic
but when we ask the
ciric proteins gossip if a share in
monoclonal proteins underlying the
serum proteins  total go higher than
normal so we don't see we will for
example find a normal albumin or an
albumin lowered by the tablea  u
inflammatory and presto we find a
very high total serum protein level
itunes sauce it tells us
that there is probably a
share of monoclonal protein hiding
below the ground and the blood test is
really l  'monoclonal protein apparatus
is the dosage of
total immunoglobulins it is judged at gm
protein electrophoresis sygic the immuno girl
feels syria and the dosage of
light chains the ipsi sneering if these elements
there that we must ask  to
investigate the protein apparatus in the
first place we will go through each of
its different tests to clarify
everything so the monoclonal part
is really what will be secreted
by the placement below normal which
poses the organic complications of
multiple myeloma
here you have the image so you have the
heavy chain with the light chain and
that can be attached to the
heavy which it gives us an
immunoglobulin and acts and you have
the light chains that  i can be
free of a heavy chain and therefore be
light and free which will be assayed by
the light chain assay lips
éric the heavy chain of the immunoglobulin
most often it will be an ivg or an
iga that we want to find
multiple myeloma and I put gbg there it exists
but it's much rarer and the
light scenes it's going to be either capin
or lamda I'm going to missiles between the
three entities so I judge or slip a
word previously there was a lot
of myeloma  which was classified as
secreting honey or secreting aligot,
that is to say situations where the
patient presents with a
clean attack and honey but we do not find
we do not detect
circulating paraproteins in the blood and well
now that  we have the dosage of
the gerling series chains which is a very
very sensitive test you will see a little
later to detect a strict ace
munster
several of these millions who had been
categorized as non-secret  an oulipo
secreting now are categorized
as multiple myeloma the
light chain it represents about 15 to 20%
of cases of multiple myeloma that they
will not have from us but who
will present themselves alone with a chain
the jars the tapas or  high lamda and
it is an entity in its own right and
non-secreting myeloma where we would not
detect carries not at all
deschesne slight lead series which is
lifted it is very very rare now we are
talking about less than one percent  either
exists but it is very rare in general
the chains and manages the series that
we are allowed to detect dysphasia
class master I will also talk about it
a little later
when we talk about electrophoresis the
proteins syria that in  fact it's a test
that goes quantitative tech so you see
here we look at the blood level the
different proteins present of which
you have the albumen which is the large initial peak
then jean lasseille you have a
bump which is in fact  t the last wave
if I can say it is the wave of
immunoglobulins the first is beautiful
so it is at polygon immunoglobulins
at 1 without there being
monoclonal peaks when a violent but a
monoclonal peak if you look at the  the image on the
right
you will see at the end we could have the
beautiful wave as we had on the
normal image but we really note a
monoclonal peak and this the
normal immunoglobulin apart from abnormal proteins
secreted by the plasma it is  abnormal that
will be detected and that's what we
measure when we say that a
monoclonal peak has for example 20 grams per
liter the immunosuccess in Syria that it will
allow us to tell us this peak my
shareholder that  is it
exactly from what origin and it is
therefore they know to be from kelly if the
monoclonal parra protein and if you
see the bottom line it is the
monoclonal peak that we found
the ciric protein electrophoresis
and we  sees that when you want to dance there if
it's not that it's  git from a friend I'm heading
in is we also find the case not at
the eu level rim in
immunofixation it's really a
qualitative test that will tell us what type of
tara does he believe underlying we
the green elected officials lib sireix and a
very sensitive test years there is it is the ratio
between the lydia pas and lambda light chain
that we will use above all which
must be between 0.26 and 1.65 you see
the sensitivities electrophoresis will
detect a  appropriate share of 1 to 2 g
per liter
the imminence to his darling who is more
insulting the electro fareng we will go and
get monoclonal paraprotein of
points 15 points 5 grams per liter
but watch the chains light l'ilsi
rhythm we were going to look with
better sensitivity we are talking about
less than 0.001 grams per liter which is
why this test which is very sensitive
and now use just a few
points to know when used in the
clinic its active successes which
frequent situations
for example a context of  'inf  lammation
have told that infection can
raise chains people can
raise the ratio so modify our
values ​​a context of
chronic renal failure or six in
chronic renal silences
often we will see an elevation of the
light chain capa and that  secondary
mans will undermine the at sion duration so
that's all there is to say little particularity
of the test that you need is comfortable there to
handle and also to interpret so if
you can remember one thing at the level
of the chain assays the  muse of these
brawls and taxes hesitate to call
the hematologist if you have any questions
about the interpretation of this post and
its 2 2 do not hesitate to repeat the
dosage if you only have one dosage of
times of reptiles dosage allows us
to have a better interpretation of the
text
I'm just putting some studies to
show you that now it's
part of our Basque record a
little bit after his vote directed towards the
famous collection cu  linear who was this
burial what we must always
do it that it remains a big question
so I present to you here the first
study which dates from 2006 it was approximately
the 430 patients who had miyem suffered
monoclonal and the urinary expression of
the monoclonal protein apparatus were
present so I don't know that launches
edition drop the rhythm and
did the electro farrell the
immunofixation and the serial shalit assay but by
doing these three pistoles years we
only missed two of the 4,128 k  dance
0.5 percent of the patients had a
urinary monoclonal protein but the
other three tests the electro not a
fixation and the chains the giants lips
eric were all within normal limits
so that's not what we
missed by  against these two problems
under study does not require
medical intervention so it was 2nd
cus stalls and not stages where
action should have been taken
another larger study
the water near 190  0 patients with gama
building notes nasa having watched are
screened with
serum protein electrophoresis and light chains
liszt eric versus if we were to add
the minots tightened cases these two
tests and sky drop
mines at cias years  éric did not decrease
the sensitivity to detect cases of
multiple myeloma
here so I have you my summary tables
which were published in 2009 what
should we do what should we
do to the screaming of a  monoclonal appetite range
and you see here that for
our frequent pathologies like
multiple myeloma smoldering multiple myeloma which is this
m
m lmcu this just doing
serum protein electrophoresis
and
ciric free people it's enough
after all usually meets for
make up for our share of protein love
game monoclonal appetite on the other hand if
you look at the entities towards the end
which are a little rarer and sometimes
with weaker lead comm  e a
classification six graves or like amyloidosis
there on the other hand it is important to
complete with the minots 66 and even for
example in the amyloid codes with the
urinary analyzes not done
therefore the urinary collection of the 24 hours
I would tell you that it is fine  be done by
the reference center it is not a test
that is to be done in the first line in
fact of screening the monoclonal appetite range
it is still very
indicated when one suspects or my
diagnosis an amyloid at the same or even
essential at the time of diagnosis
and  during the violent during a 2011 diagnosis
it will not be used for
screening screening but
when the diagnosis is made
in general it will be carried out at
least once at the time of the diagnosis
to support the file the
patient hearing and lead  so in the harbor in the
front line
the ticket office bone marrow
biocides bone marrow this refusal by
the reference center but it is a
piece that really allows us to establish  ir
the place word story medullary therefore
to fetch water
more information on the disease of the patient
whose genetics the genetics of
multiple myeloma is increasingly
important it guides our treatments it
guides the taker sig station also
so it  it is really with the bbc the
bone marrow that we are going to get
this information there and also it
allows us to see if there can be a
concomitant presence of amyloid
audousset to pronounce it angles a small world
again as I have just  tell you we
will look for them especially with the genetics
which will excess by sich aquitain
special test at the level of the ticket office of
the bone marrow but to know that there are
nevertheless certain blood tests which
will help us to establish the prognosis
of the patient according to  the score is there it is this
targeted cry it is the international staging score
which takes into account
genetics but also the values ​​of beta
2 micro albumin globulin siriki of
ldh then c  e why you will
often see these tests the request and in
our range report has suffered
monoclonal imaging imaging on the ground I would like
that in the front line we are going to be in pid
do an x-ray a serious
metastatic it is a good
screening test but it takes good
bone damage to see the disputes
on the x-ray so more and more
the investigations of a range of
monoclonal apathy we are moving towards
more sensitive imaging techniques tacot
resonance and even the pet scan that  we will
see more and more use of the
next few years in the contexts
sometimes the two-seater mostow soft half
so medal years that we want well and on
hidden active myeloma hood that it would
cause a
different care with treatment in
really the imagery is to push
when you have a suspicion ali maybe
with a taco a resonance to see
fate not detect something the
x-ray would have missed a suspicion
danil  o hondo it's more at the
internal level yesui at the
second third line level perhaps but sometimes
can also present or if you are a
family doctor it's sure that jungle just a
word in need that it takes a balance sheet which
will be much more  extensive
because the organ hatem ception
different in the dausque melody
compared to the mit then multiple
so now that we have spoken of 15
suspects and the trauma multiple myeloma
the figs and I end by
giving you the leads of caen referred the
patient to the hemato-oncology team
if you have an active male nest
it's just that you have
demonstrated it well with the diagnostic criteria
the new criteria of 2014 if you
are affected by a target organ  it is an
urgent reference
from the outset it is urgent the patient fingering
due quickly and the treatment will
start quickly in hematology
because also the longer we wait the longer the
delays plio complications
unfortunately if you have a p  had the
fifth goal of view these intermediate
or high so it will present an
education of the man of biopsies of the
bone marrow
it is an education of referred in
hematology so that we can proceed to
this biopsy given the recommendations
followed to the needs are
suspect amyloidosis also it makes me happy to
evaluate in hematology to clarify the
question and all this work
is only in begu you have seen
it multiple myeloma it is sneaky its
multiple long faces sometimes we are
annoyed  and good to do that is to have
the patient assessed in hematology for
a good full round that is a
referral indication or if first line
first line care these
successes when the patient presents
with the complications of
multiple myeloma  do not hesitate to refer these
patients to the emergency room if necessary if
severe anemia with two inaccuracies
acute hypercalcemia which must
be managed with hydration a
biphosph  onates nascent severe
kidney neurological compression nantes
referred these passers-by there the emergency the
best way for a
quick
treatment he begs me but because myeloma patients might
need urgent radiotherapy urgent surgeries
where still dialysis
depending on common presents  here
sometimes the body friends of
urgent complications but it's passers-by who
see a sight quickly in hematology
but it's patients who sometimes
have pain
so to adjust the analgesia while waiting for
the consultation the care or  if
to adjust the medication nessus
resulting in something that we
sometimes forget lemay who is also important is
hungry
and in short the reference in hematology the more
the reference that will be sent
to us will be complete the
more we will be able to give an adequate period of time
to see each  patient
i.e. if I have a request for
consultations with just
ciric protein electrophoresis
and for  the dosage of the chalet gerling
syria for example I could hand
classify the patient there to ensure that
an additional delay is added a patient
who has for example a chain the
airs at 13000 will be treated differently
than a fifth chain the isère has
however something 50 so really
to have a complete balance sheet of your time
the protein it will help to better orient
your patient in adequate time
and this poetry you are also called
the hematology team if you are
bothered on a balance sheet  ask or on
the orientation of the patient it is
always a pleasure to answer
questions so conclusion I hope that
this would be binary will have
really helped you for the health professionals on the
front line who you
really have an essential role to
play  saw the patients with put in the shade
multiple comes to you in the front
line in the star who with the webinar
your place equipped for suspects
there is the man and recognize him with himself  s
different clinical presentations that
you are also better equipped to
request the basic investigation our
different tests are better equipped to
refer the patient quickly because
once again I have on the message
adequate and
rapid front-line care  it's essential for
the patient we avoid the complications
that can arise when we have
additional delays
so here I am ready now
for the questions thank you for this
excellent presentation from their
very informative side and then
indeed we still have a little bit left  time
for a few questions before moving
on to question period i would like to
remind the audience that to submit
your questions you must type them in
the box and then which you can
access by clicking on the green
button in the bottom corner  to the left
of the presentation screen is one of the
first questions which appeared
these concerts the electrophoresis ur  ary
but you partially answered
too much urinary ease requires
urine collection over 24 hours but
can we ask for it at
diagnosis instead of free light chains
so then if we have touched
on the subject a little in the  presentation but I
would tell you that the essential thing for a
first-line diagnostic screening
is not to collect
24-hour urine samples with 1900 the
dosage of light schemes in the
Celtic league will give us very good
sensitivity, you have it  seen at the level of the
various studies that I have therefore shown
to combine electrophoresis and
ciric proteins with the assay of
light chains the two series that by
generating it is quite sufficient to
suspect and tracks and
multiple myeloma in the first line no  really
the urine tests I would tell you that in the
first line my ex and where for example
by the last under the nose frolov are going to
be it is much more in
situations where one suspects  a friend
the eye dose or like a
urinary nephrotic syndrome for example so there
yes it is really recommended to
complete the assessment with the
urinary collection of 24 hours and the minutes
are minor but as far as
May 1st screening is concerned,
we do not  does more inard co-reading
now in a package is long
it will probably be once at the
diagnosis to find out if the patient
has benjo proteinuria but
for screening in Geneva the
young players have taken the place of
urine collection
ok goes precisely in the foam in the
same line of what this question there
in certain institutions when the
12 of the free light chains is requested
by a general practitioner
the dosage is not always carried out
so there a question is why is
this  that this is not carried out or how
can we ensure that it is done then
here at the level of another sense which
available or family doctors so a
family doctor p  had to ask for it and
will have the result I would like that
in the centers where it is not
possible
probably that the way to obtain
it is to call the hematology department
to discuss with the hematologist of
the patient's body  that you have sometimes it can
probably add additional delays
in the investigation
of a patient who is a part of his own
hymn to electro by the we want to
complete with the dosage of slight lipsic schemes
so I would say to you that it is
communicate with the person who would
allow you to add this test there
because it should be unavailable for
our first line
as you have seen it is part of the
assessment and it also helps us in the
references in hematology dressed
decide on the delay  in
special charge we
ok again we still have time
maybe for a last question
this one in a more general rate that
you have also and not badly addressed the
point but the symptoms of
multiple myeloma  the are often non-specific
as you have well underlined but
what allows you to suspect
multiple myeloma a range with
monoclonal tati more than anything else that there are
particular points that must be
systematically thought out to  to be
able to suspect that and then start
all there the whole process to be able to
identify a protein part I
would like asthma and it is to have
the famous the famous
clinical presentation and the different faces of
multiple myeloma have them in peace
stay  on the lookout
it is certain that an older patient who
presents an enemy the balance sheet by to
protect part of the balance sheet from the limits to
kidney failure
yes it can be diabetes is happening to
a cb tic but to keep a  a flea in
the ear if however the diabetes is
well controlled ah well there it is perhaps
to look a little further and to
think of the protein apparatus so the
limit often it is easier to
think about it easier  to add it in
our assessment
the renal sufficiency or if we will
see it often
sometimes what is a little more difficult
it is the famous bone pains
so the bone pains I think
it is good to do a good
physical examination an imagery to try to
see  if there is something under jospin
this pain this globe but on
keeping in mind ski frethun and fraikin
everything that is rare is rare but
vereecke it is to try to have a flea
in your ear if a pain  for example
of musculoskeletal origin do
not fit into lord with a
physiotherapy approach or anti-
inflammatories so the
basic treatment the standard treatment push
further at the level of imaging at the level of the
blood test and even if the patient is
young that  can be a presentation of
myeloma so i would like it is to
stay tuned who arise ip to
think about it and asked for tests
thanks again from their side for your
involvement in
today's webinar i  would like to clarify that
we will endeavor to answer
individually all the questions
that have been asked today and that
we have not been able to address due to lack
of time dr what do you have a
last comment to close this
session this  is a big thank you to you
I hope to have given you the tools and
the information necessary to
suspect multiple myeloma and a big thank you
for the organization of the binary
thank you well I would also like to thank
for baoding that which made possible
educational activities today  Today this
webinar will soon be available
for viewing on demand
you will receive an email from the bush
to inform you of the date on which
it will be available for re-reading and
I also invite you to share this
seminar with your colleagues who were
unable to  attend today's presentation
thank you all and enjoy